in our series on the financial fallout
from the coronavirus we're looking at
how minority households and minority
businesses are being affected the most
as a millions of Americans filed for
unemployment benefits listen to the
numbers 29% of white households lost a
job took a pay cut or experienced both
now that number jumps to 36 percent of
black households black households rather
and nearly half of Hispanic households
John Hope Bryant is a founder and CEO of
Operation Hope that's a non-profit
providing financial literacy and
empowerment to underserved communities
he's advised three u.s. presidents and
is currently working with the Trump
administration good morning to you John
Hope Bryant it's good to see you listen
I think all smaller services are really
struggling at this time yeah good to see
you John all small businesses are
struggling at this time but what are you
finding and what are you hearing from
minority business owners in particular
well when mainstream America has a
headache black and brown folks have
pneumonia
we're all sick today it sort of hurts a
little bit more maybe a lot more of your
black business because you don't have
the infrastructure of the finance
department the accounting department
this is the back room sophistication
because most these businesses are very
small one to four employees to be able
to power through the paperwork and the
constant changes of the program as well
as it is well intentioned as a program
is so they need the resources like
operation hope to be that bridge that
catalyst so they can get into the
application pool to get this money so
what are you doing exactly we're doing
credit counseling we're doing we're
having folks to qualify for the Care Act
we're helping businesses to qualify to
the Care Act so please call us the
services are free we're helping to
consumer people who are watching your
program to modify their mortgage modify
their small business well modify their
their credit cards to reset their life
negotiate with their landlord you don't
have an advocate right now and what I
keep saying is you know the color has
changed Gail it used to be red and
in politics used to be black and white
as in race now the color is green
whether you're white black red brown
yellow today you want to see some more
green we also want to see some
environmental sustainability but today
the color the meaty color is economic
green and everybody's got to get focused
on that you're not gonna get as much
money as you want you know you did it as
quickly as you like you're not going to
necessarily like the process but the
money on the other side is real it's the
first time in US history the government
actually given you a check you know in
Mickey's you ought to pay it back so get
in line I'm telling everybody go get
your money it's not complaining about
the color of it or the size of it go get
your money the money is real on the
other side it's frustrating but it's
real on the other side so how do they
get the money that's the question
everybody's asking how do you do that I
like what you said finances don't
discriminate it's not black or white
it's the color is green and we're all in
this together I've heard you say so how
do you get the money yeah unfortunately
we didn't get the memo on money and
unfortunately we're in the middle of a
crisis trying to figure it out no one
got a financial literacy lesson there's
no not there's no time now to give you a
lecture about it it's time you get in
line so what you have to do is you've
got to find an SBA approved lender you
do not have to have an account with them
every banks criteria is the same go find
a small bank that everybody should be
going to big banks go find a small bank
of credit units or CDFI or a fin tech
firm on online to prove with the SBA get
in the shortest time possible the
smallest most discreet institution
that's approved that has the lowest
level of applications in their pipeline
that's what you want to go and if you're
confused call us at Operation Hope
because our services are free we just
your advocate we're like we're like the
Starbucks of Financial Inclusion but
again the color today is green in you're
never going to get a check like this
from the federal government for free
ever again if you're a non-profit you
get a check you're a church you get a
check you're a small business you get a
check everybody will get at least
$10,000 but you've got to apply and you
got to do it now because they're running
out every day essentially Gail they
stood up the tenth largest bank in
America in 15 days of course is going to
be
okay of course it's gonna be ready fire
aim nothing's gonna work well and every
process got to be broken but what do we
expect so we just we can complain about
it later at the moment go get your green
and call us if you have problems we'll
help you you know your your your
organization is called Operation Hope
and no pun intended because you do see
hope and you do see inspiration despite
this time what is that job well all the
stuff we're not doing yeah I mean think
about this we have frustrations in our
governments and all that kind of stuff
going on and we can't agree on much but
there's no writing
there's no looting people are being kind
to each other people are building
bridges to each other they're there they
are loving each other they're being
gracious corporations and leaders are
doing incredible things with their own
wealth employers are being incredibly
compassionate but the thing that
everybody is doing your viewers are
doing is being kind and loving to each
other that's the American spirit that is
a role model for the world listen listen
no riding or looting crime is actually
down even the crumbs are like
everybody's getting the memo and that's
really in some job here it it's so
important for the spirit when at times
it can seem spiritually and emotionally
draining so what do you think we can
learn from this America's lesson about
her strengths and her weaknesses at this
particular time and what we need well
we're resilient people give up from
nothing and in rainbows only follow
storms that's a scientific fact you
cannot have a rainbow without a storm
first I think this is a reset we didn't
learn the lesson I guess guy was like
look I tried to tell you about wealth
and income inequality you didn't listen
I tried to tell you that politics should
be co-opted collaborative and
cooperative and compassionate we didn't
listen I try to tell you that racism is
stupid well commence it from the same
DNA you didn't listen but worst of all
we didn't sustain our small planet and I
think the guy didn't send us a reboot he
didn't kill us but he said it's a reset
to get us our attention everybody's
attention to the same
deal billionaires millionaires and I'm
trying to buy some they're all I got the
number with the same time and next yeah
the lesson for us on the other side
you're right you're right we are all
paying attention with both ears in both
eyes thank you John Hope Bryant for
taking the time this morning we really
appreciate it